MOVED ON BUT I HAVEN'T AND YOU
SHOULDN'T EITHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
♪♪
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT TO FIRE
YOU.
EVERYTHING YOU DID WHILE YOU
WERE AT IF FBI WAS FOR YOUR
POLITICAL AND EGOTISTICAL
ADVANTAGE, STARTING WITH
ANNOUNCING THAT NO REASONABLE
PROSECUTOR WOULD PROSECUTE
HILLARY CLINTON TO YOUR
ARROGANCE IN REMOVING CLASSIFIED
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION FROM
THE FBI AND GIVING INFORMATION
TO YOUR PAL IN ORDER TO GET IT
TO THE "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
BY DOING THIS, YOU, ONE PERSON,
JAMES COMEY, YOU CREATED HAVOC
AND CHAOS IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
BUT FOR YOUR DOING THAT, ROBERT
MUELLER WOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED AND AMERICA WOULD
NEVER HAVE HAD TO ENDURE THE
LIES OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION THAT
YOU AND YOUR PALS IN THE FBI
CREATED.
YOUR ARROGANCE, JIM, LED YOU TO
BELIEVE ONCE AGAIN THAT YOU WERE
ABOVE THE LAW.
YOU TOOK VARIOUS DOCUMENTS THAT
CONTAIN CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
AND OFFICIAL USE ONLY AND YOU
REMOVED THEM FROM THE FBI.
BY DOING SO, YOU VIOLATED BOTH
THE FBI'S RULES AND POLICIES AS
WELL AS THE TERMS OF YOUR FBI
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT.
AFTER BEING FIRED, RIGHTFULLY
FIRED AS DIRECTOR BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP, YOU TOOK SEVEN MEMOS THAT
YOU HAD NO RIGHT TO REMOVE FROM
THE FBI THAT YOU NEVER TOLD
ANYONE ABOUT AND YOU PLACED THEM
IN YOUR SAFE.
THIS IS CONTRARY TO THE RULES OF
THE ESTEEMED FBI, MORE ESTEEMED
SINCE YOU LEFT.
AND WHEN YOU LEFT, YOU WERE
REQUIRED TO SURRENDER ALL
MATERIALS IN YOUR POSSESSION
THAT CONTAINED FBI INFORMATION.
YOU DID NOT.
YOU SENT SOME TO YOUR PAL,
RICHMOND TO GET TO THE "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" WITHOUT SEEKING THE
NECESSARY FBI AUTHORIZATION
UNDER THE CLAIM THAT THEY WERE
SIMPLY YOUR PERSONAL MEMOS.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
MAKES IT VERY CLEAR THAT MERELY
LABELING A DOCUMENT PERSONAL OR
PRIVATE DOES NOT ALTER ITS
OFFICIAL NATURE.
YOU GAVE SOME OF THOSE MEMOS TO
YOUR ATTORNEYS.
THE REPORTS INCLUDED THAT YOU
IMPROPERLY DISCLOSED THAT
INFORMATION AND THAT YOU WERE
NOT AUTHORIZED TO DO THAT.
YOU SIMPLY DECIDED TO TAKE
MATTERS INTO YOUR OWN HANDS.
YOUR LACK OF CANDOR AND YOUR
INABILITY TO BE STRAIGHTFORWARD
AND RETURN THOSE RECORDS, AS
WELL AS YOUR FAILURE TO REVEAL
THAT YOU TOOK THOSE RECORDS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE FBI, SENT BY
ANDREW McCABE, CAME TO YOUR
HOME TO INVENTORY AND REMOVE ALL
OF THE FBI PROPERTY YOU TOOK.
YOU DID NOT SAY, WHEN YOU HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY AND OBLIGATION,
THAT YOU HAD FBI PROPERTY IN
YOUR SAFE.
THOSE MEMOS THAT CONTAINED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION HAD TO BE
SECURED AT A SKIFF AND YOU KNOW
IT, A SENSITIVE EXART MENTAL
FACILITY.
BUT YOUR ARROGANCE HAS NO
BOUNDS.
AFTER THE REPORT CAME OUT YOU
WERE QUICK TO ATTACK THOSE WHO
HAD TALKED FOR YEARS ABOUT YOUR
GOING TO JAIL FOR BEING A LIAR
AND A LEAKER.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT YOU SAID
LAST YEAR.
>> I DIDN'T CONSIDER IT PART OF
AN FBI FILE.
>> YOU WROTE IT AS AN FBI
DIRECTOR PIPT WAS WORK PRODUCT.
>> NO, IT DOES NOT.
IT WAS MY PERSONAL.
>> BUT
.> BUT
JU BUT
JUDGUT
JUDGE JEANINE: BUT WHEN THE
REPORT CAME OUT THE IG SAID,
QUOTE, ALL COMEY WELL KNEW,
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IS NEVER
CONSIDERED PERSONAL PROPERTY.
RATHER IT IS THE PROPERTY OF THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
YOU KNOW, JIM, IN YOUR TWEET,
YOU COMPLAIN ABOUT ALL OF THOSE
WHO SPENT YEARS TALKING ABOUT
YOUR GOING TO JAIL OR ABOUT
BEING A LIAR OR A LEAKER.
BUT LIKE ALL LIARS AND LEAKERS,
YOU'VE GOT YOURSELF CONVINCED
THAT YOU DIDN'T LIE,
THAT YOU DIDN'T LIE.
JIM, READ THE REPORTS.
YOU VIOLATED THE RULES AND CUT
HILLARY CLINTON LOOSE ON THE
SAME STATUTE THAT YOU COULD HAVE
BEEN CHARGED WITH.
YOU KNEW BETTER THAN ANYONE THAT
WHAT YOU WERE DOING WAS WRONG.
AND IF YOU WANT TO READ MORE
ABOUT YOURSELF AFTER I WROTE
ABOUT YOU IN "LIARS, LEAKERS AND
LIBERALS," MY NEW BOOK
"RADICALS, RESISTANCE AND
REVENGE, THE LEFT'S PLOT TO
REMAKE AMERICA" GIVES YOU TOP
BILLING AGAIN.
DON'T YOU DARE TELL US THAT WE
ARE THE LIARS AND THE LEAKERS.
YOU ARROGANT SANCTIMONIOUS
CONDESCENDING LOW LIFE.
YOU HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE A LIAR
AND THE LEAKER.
AND JUST BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IS NOT PROSECUTING
YOU ON THIS, DON'T THINK FOR ONE
SECOND THAT YOU'RE HOME FREE,
BUDDY.
IF NOTHING MORE, YOU'RE
IF NOTHING MORE, YOURRE
IF NOTHING MORE, YOUR LYING AND
LEAKING SHOWS YOUR INTENT TO
TAKE DOWN DONALD TRUMP AND YOUR
ABUSE OF OUR COURTS IN ORDER TO
DO JUST THAT.
EGGER YOU DID HERE IS JUST
ANOTHER REMINDER OF YOUR PUTTING
YOUR PERSONAL AMBITION AND EGO
AHEAD OF OUR COUNTRY AND
PATRIOTISM.
OF YOUR ATTEMPT TO GET EVEN
BECAUSE YOU WERE FIRED.
AND OF YOUR HATRED SO INTENSE
THAT YOU CAUSED THIS COUNTRY TO
ALMOST FRACTURE OVER THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR AND THE ABSURD IDEA
OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
SURE, THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
MAY HAVE DECLINED PROSECUTING
YOU ON THIS.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, JIM, YOUR
ATTEMPT TO FRAME A PRESIDENT AND
SURVEIL AN AMERICAN CITIZEN TO
SPY ON A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
FOR YOUR GIRLFRIEND HILLARY THAT
YOU CUT LOOSE AND THEN USED THE
DOSSIER PAID FOR WITH HER MONEY,
MONEY LAUNDERED THROUGH A LAW
ENFORCEMENT
LAFORCEMENT
LAWORCEMENT
LAWFICEMENT
LAWFIRMMENT
LAWFIRM TNT
LAWFIRM TOT
LAWFIRM TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP